[Musik]
das wird so das intro auf visits weiter
diese begrüßen debatte zu bekommen hast
du schon mal ein youtube gesehen jetzt
einfach zur begrüßung treffe ich noch
nicht dieser moment kannst du dich
jeremy froh jetzt mit ferrari
kennst du den nächten leute was gedacht
von herzlich willkommen bei einem neuen
video
da wollte ich habe mir natürlich geht es
gut mir auch danke der nachfrage in den
letzten ein zwei wochen kam es schon
zwei von zehn kostenlosen milchprodukten
und ich habe euch glaube ich schon mal
erzählt dass ich ein riesen einkauft und
getätigt habe und ich habe insgesamt
über 30 kostenlose michaty viel gekauft
wie kreuz wäre die schlauberger in den
kommentaren und not ist wird anderes man
kann immer den versand mit ja da hat er
recht versand kostet halt immer zwei
euro also 100% kostenlos ist es nicht
allerdings werden die dort als kostenlos
angegeben und sich deshalb alle diese
sachen die dort als kostenlos angegeben
werden weil es halt manchmal kompletter
quatsch ist und manchmal ist doch geil
und wenn du hier mit der kamera
unterwegs deswegen meine adresse
geworfen einschließlich das sind alles
sachen noch angekommen sind und ich muss
sagen das sind 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11
13 14 sachen und ich habe keine ahnung
welche davon überhaupt dazu gehören
deswegen müssen wir einfach alles
auspacken weil da müssten auch noch
sachen dabei seien die halt nicht in
diesem part reihen sollen ich will aber
eigentlich gar nicht eingeladen und wir
fangen direkt mal an wichtig ist aber zu
sagen abonniert den kanal aktiviert die
glocke jeden tag 19 uhr gibt es hier ein
neues video baby und gerne auch über
installieren die alle zwei weitere ideen
oder weitere produkte die ich gerne
testen einfach zu schicken
super wichtig dass auch ideen von euch
kommen dann möchte dass lady durchziehen
kann
und jetzt frauen und stuhl dann setze
ich mich erst mal kurz ich finde also
ich habe keine ahnung warum dieses paket
gelb ist das hat noch nie ein gelbes ich
habe noch nie ein gelbes paket gesehen
müssen wir aufmachen oder da bin ich mal
gespannt wie ihr bestellt habe ich was
ist das neben den lampen der lampe das
revier bestellt und spaß war nämlich gar
nicht daran erinnern ich glaube das ist
ein pool lampe weil ich aber noch so
cool wie chips bestellt aber ich bin mir
nicht sicher wie sich jetzt erstmal zur
seite ich konnte mir das gleich mal aber
guck mal da geht das funktioniert ja
auch gar nicht so bestellte pool lampe
hat mich heute interessiert erst einmal
in köln youtube party hast du dieses
bild hier mal gesehen
gut also dass wir jetzt erst mal
irgendwas was hier glauben nicht
reingehört es tut mir sehr leid okay
dann hoffe ich jetzt aber hier ist was
drin was wir heute wirklich gebrauchen
können um ernst sein wir haben hier
ich habe keine ahnung doch ich weiß es
glaube ich ich weiß du willst dich so
tot lachen wenn du mich damit liest was
auf und zwar habe ich davon glaube ich
schon mal erzählt dass ahlmann liegt das
an was ist denn das für mit kaffee ist
ja überall keine batterie drin oder will
man hier ein das sieht irgendwie übels
mitgenommen aus oder wenn man hier als
hätte das schon mal irgendwann benutzt
oder aber noch nach aha jetzt
funktioniert ist leuchtet und jetzt
zeige ich euch auch mal wofür das gut
ist das habe ich mir nämlich extra
bestellt weil ich neuerdings hier der
kölner pfadfindergruppe beigetreten bin
glaubt ihm halt weil er erst dann nur
jetzt erzählen kann das ist eine super
fahrt findet
[Musik]
ist doch geil oder was immer jetzt muss
ich mal kurz mal gucken ob deswegen kurz
für das war
wir müssen wir ganz kurz irgendwohin wo
es dunkel ist damit man das mal checken
johannes leuchtet ist schon nicht
schlecht kommen immer noch immer die
kamera
ich mache das ich zeige euch das jetzt
mal aus meiner sicht heißt es ist schon
was der leiste hier
man kann sich genau dem weg war also die
helligkeit ist auf jeden fall da geile
sketche lagerkosten leute so das ganze
video an ich habe ich wollte gerade
sagen ich hätte halt das einfach den
rest funktionieren ist nämlich geil weil
dann kann ich direkt die ganzen sachen
auch noch besser sehen okay was haben
wir noch machen wir mal hieß es weiter
das wollen wir dass das ist sehr oft
falsch an weißt du was es ist ja das ist
förster 2 soll nur einmal kurz nein nein
nein nein war dabei auf macht gar nein
nein nicht in erholung alter nicht
dicker das ist tot macht bitte nicht
leute schreibt man die kommentare an die
die sich mit pfefferspray auskennen weil
ich habe jetzt zwei first rays von muss
bestellt nicht dass wir hier die
wohnungen evakuieren müssen
ok jetzt habe ich das nächste produkt
und zwar das ist was richtig gutes für
dich ruhig weißt du was das ist habe ich
bestellt gratis krass dass es
funktioniert hast du mal eine zigarette
sicher also ich bin strikt nichtraucher
ich brauche wirklich nicht das hier ist
aber nicht für zigaretten kostenlos
passen wir auch und zwar weißt du was
man damit machen kann
erstmal haben den usb stick beleuchtet
das eigentlich noch nie hört sieht das
gut aus
wir haben einen usb stick ich checke
euch mal wie für gigabit da drauf sind
und jetzt pass auf du wirst vom glauben
abfallen fällt es nur und jetzt was auf
louis du wirst vom glauben abfallen
es funktioniert und jetzt muss sie also
nicht
ich rauche den mädchen in der wohnung
ist verschwunden der wohnung macht dich
aus und dient auch nicht zu ändern ist
so eklig mehr endlich zeigt dass ich
nicht nur auf die kosten leute kleiner
fehler passieren irgendwie es die kamera
explodiert und die spartaner beschädigt
weswegen wir jetzt die letzten drei
sachen nochmal auspacken können weil die
ganze datei ist weg fragt mich gerade
ein bisschen ab aber uns bleibt gar
nichts anderes übrig werden als erstes
auf jeden fall hier soll bluetooth
wireless speaker den kann man an jeder
station anschließen und dann halt
darüber oder den mit dem handy verbinden
und das wurde wirklich als kostenloses
technik wird mir angezeigt ob das
funktioniert weiß ich nicht deswegen
springen wir jetzt mal eben zur
jugendzimmer der ist nämlich dj und ich
stecke das sommer in seine dj anlage und
dann gucken wir auf der vernünftig sound
rauskommen ob ich das verbinden kann
werde schon geld so leute da bin ich mal
gespannt was sie kann
hier sitzt checke ich mal auch für
diesen kleinen kreis ding hier finden
ist es ein gutes gehabt hier ist es
schon alter die technik von heute
unschlagbar leider ich bin verbunden und
jetzt mag spotify an
wenn das klappt dann freut mich ganz zu
anfang mit dem kleinen gerät
ein bisschen rauschen oder bei der
anlage ist es zehn jahre alt
die währung das ist übrigens apropos led
ich habe bei bis acht leds bestellt da
gibt es ein mega fan video zu durch leds
für die toilette für die dusche alles
mögliche weitergeht als nächste sache
wie man schon an diesem wunderschönen
tisch sehen kann
hatten wir ich dachte erst dass wenn so
wachsmalstifte oder so weil ich mich
nicht mehr daran erinnern konnte was ich
da bestellt habe auf jeden fall sind das
so kajalstift für die augen die er war
auch optimal sind um zu um auf t shirts
zu zeichnen oder einwände nicht anwende
des gestrigen bin ich ab das ist schöne
grüße auch an unsere vermieterin
verstreichen das wieder auf jeden fall
war da meine frage an euch mädels wenn
ihr euch diesen stift hier anschaut ist
das ein vernünftiger stift kann man
damit arbeiten oder ist das der größte
reiz schritt den chinesischen zeichen
irgendwas drauf kann ich eh nicht lesen
kann
ich schenke ich meiner freundin ok und
irgendwas genau über das nächste habe
ich mich so aufgeregt ich musste erst
mal ziemlich lange überlegen wofür das
denn jetzt wirklich war
ich zeige es euch mal hin und zwar haben
wir hier ein ich habe den namen schon
wieder vergessen
man steckt es auf jeden fall in die nase
und ich dachte erst das wäre gegen
schnarchen also dass man halt nicht
schlecht weil das nervt wenn man
irgendwie zu zweit im bett dick oder so
dann habe ich eben mal gegoogelt und bin
darauf gekommen dass das gegen
nasenspray ist also wenn man erkennt ist
ihr könnt ihr dieses nasenspray und dann
hier dieses teil in die nase steckt
könnt ihr gut atmen was ich sehr stark
bezweifeln mag zweite sache die auch
noch hinzu kommt das stinkt so
übertrieben nachwuchs krams oder china
schrott komplett nach plastik und wenn
ich das in meine nase stöcke was erstens
total erotischen gut aussieht
so muss ich lesen das wird so das intro
vielleicht sind da irgendwelche
wirkstoffe dringen die einst ein
bisschen benebelt machen auf jeden fall
bin ich der meinung dass bringt absolut
gar nichts und es macht ein ich weiß ich
dann danach ich glaube mit einer nacht
schläft mit diesem gerät hier hast du
irgendwelche komischen komischen
substanzen im körper so plastik party
gop verteilt standen deinem ganzen kreis
ich glaube wir lasst besser die finger
von sich auch für wer findest du warst
also komplett komiker gut und waffen ich
habe absolut keine ahnung was das sein
soll gab es möglich für mich weiß auch
zu lassen komme hier muss man glaube ich
diese nadel reintun und dann kann man
das mit helium gefüllt wahrscheinlich
jetzt habe ich ein kleines ein kleines
loch habe ich da kommt genau hier drin
ist es egal war kostenlos braucht kein
mensch weiß dinge fertig so mir reicht
es auch langsam kommen wir zum letzten
projekt das auch immer das ist habe ich
ja schon gestellt deute ich komme so
durcheinander ehrlich ich habe hier 50
pakete liegen irgendwie kann sein auch
ex stressen water publikum an den kann
man in wasser halten ach nee da war für
meinen pool party hier erwarten wir hier
haben wir noch eins ja immer noch 1 habt
ihr doch ein schönes messer gegeben ich
hoffe dass nicht wieder hin und ich habe
gesagt das sind leute das hier ist das
letzte das habe ich einmal durch feiert
wartet also kannst hast keine ahnung was
es sein kann dass auch ich weiß dass mir
die zugesteuert aussehen
es war so klar wenn es war klar das ist
voll im trend komme und hier
ja leute also das ist wie heißt du x
septembre konzeptes ja fünf stück hier
auch kostenlos da habe ich mich
natürlich habe ich mir natürlich nicht
entgehen das und das angebot und das gut
ist dann natürlich man muss sich nicht
komplett durch die nadeln stechen man
kann so einfach wieder rausziehen heute
ich hab so hunger irgendwie das war's
mit dem zunächst letzten part von dem
kostenlosen risch artikeln wenn ihr sagt
mach mal auf jeden fall noch ein fahrrad
schreibt in die kommentare
sprengt den like-button vielleicht kann
ich das hier auch mal mit einer anderen
plattform testen und das war es von mir
checkt auf jeden fall mein instagram als
alex wie weitere video den einfach mich
da voll war oder in die kommentare
schreiben
daumen nach oben abonnieren dort
aktivieren lesern uns morgen 19 uhr
wieder da gibt's neues video
haut rein ich geh jetz auch die gamescom
gamescom gamescom müssen immer noch
nicht auf zehn minuten oder was genau so
muss es gleich schnell